le retrait ou un référendum sur la
réforme des retraites voilà ce que
demande le parti communiste qui a tenu
tout à l'heure une conférence de presse
est lundi à l'assemblée nationale le pc
va déposer une motion référendaire
elle nécessite 58 députés signataires
elle permettra de demander au président
de la république de soumettre la réforme
des retraites au référendum écouter les
députés sénateurs communistes ont pour
stratégie d'abord d'expliquer d'
éclairer les français sur le contenu de
ce texte mais notre stratégie va être
aussi de demander au gouvernement au
président de la république de
d'organiser un référendum pour que le
peuple français et le dernier mot sur ce
texte de loi et c'est un moment
important de souveraineté nationale que
de permettre à nos concitoyens de
pouvoir exercer leur choix
la démocratie de pouvoir voter sur ce
texte de loi au final c'est une journée
capitale parce qu'il s'agit de
concrétiser notre initiative de déposer
une motion référendaire
c'est à dire d'avoir sur une feuille
les 58 signature à un moment donné qui
nous permettront de déposer cette motion
sur le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
tout ça ça fera quoi qu'il en soit
reculer le débat et puis on passe par un
amendement par amendement pour
décortiquer pour détricoter ce projet de
loi et montre à quel point des néfastes